freunde was geht ich melde mich mal als
mal was geht herum zu meinem heutigen
video draußen ist richtig gutes wetter
und ich habe mir ein haufen wasserbomben
gekauft ich werde es ein paar
wasserbomben fertig machen geht dann
raus wo ich mich ein paar freunden
treffe zum grillen auch bei youtube am
start dann spielen wir richtig oder
wasser mit wasserbomben gleich mit und
dementsprechend berlin sache wir sind
vielleicht mein gesicht an meinem job
jedenfalls sehen was wir haben gemacht
wir gehen es sowieso jetzt angekommen
habe gerade gegrillt ich sage euch mal
die runde wir haben
julia ich weiß den anton stelle mich als
erstes den fragen und krieg
wahrscheinlich eine wasserbombe ins
gericht also letzten drei wasserbomben
da war ich habe zwei getragen ich dachte
mir ich bin jetzt dran mit fragen habt
ihr auf den boden gelegt und einfach
geplatzt einfach über das wären die
norton boden gelegt wie selten auf einem
steinbruch wo kein ticket einer wissen
kann also wie gesagt ich stelle mich als
erstes den fragen julia ist so nett uns
interviewt milch wir müssen wissen fünf
fragen muss man richtig beantworten dann
hat man es geschafft dann ist man raus
das ist übertrieben es schwer weil ich
mich für verein passiert bin aber ich
weiß von diesem lieb kagawa shinji bvb
bvb 09 jahr das ist falsch das buch
seele geschrieben
wie kamst du dein erstes sage ja was ist
so schlimm ist es noch nicht zu wissen
was interessiert uns aber nicht mache
jetzt eine scheiße augen zu alter
zufällig denn er war richtig aber ich
bin ja also hab ich regel das buch warum
kenne ich dann den titel wenn die
diskussion hat dieses buch nummer also
zumindest habe ich jetzt vielleicht hat
dies auch geschrieben aber ich habe das
so verstanden bei den google titeln das
ist nicht geschrieben
die nächste wasserwanderer für julian
leute ich fand ihn fragen waren ziemlich
schwer deshalb nämlich für julias
logischerweise auch überhaupt nichts
wäre die rechtsstaat ist nämlich für
juli auf eine schwere frage wir fangen
an ok wir fangen leicht an hat köln hat
köln mehr als eine million einwohner
also seine antwort war ja richtig
ok 32 okay das berichtet das wall
schlimm oder
die erste frage ist schnell beantwortet
die nächste park ist nicht einfach würde
auch das richtig versteht wie lautet die
chemische zusammensetzung von wasser
[Musik]
so will hartz iv de einloggen
ich habe vielleicht gerne was haben doch
eine der hosen okay gesagt also um 321
schon wieder richtig nicht damit dass
über das battle gegen max schon gewonnen
das ist zwar richtig aber meine fragen
waren auch einfacher dieses video die
zerstörung der cdu mehr als 13,5
millionen unique ich habe das letzte mal
geschaut hat er zwölf scheint für das
könnte ja auch von hast du immer noch
vor dass diese themen
in zukunft will ich sage jetzt einfach
ja weil wenn es hier falsch ist dann bin
ich wenigstens sagen hat jedes fahrzeug
ist vorgesehen dass es ja auch mit allen
15 was du gewonnen und krieg seine
freiwasser vom in mein gesicht
aber da muss ich noch mal überlegen drei
nach vorne schauen
zwei wieder richtig fuß fasste ist hat
der youtuber tanzverbot mehr als eine
million abonnenten war frei das schon
wieder recht damit langweilt okay aber
sie jetzt zu sagen der zu frage lautet
was können wir gleich einen indem wir
eine wasserbombe reinwerfen es gibt
sieben harry potter teile nenne mir die
namen von vier
die kammer des schreckens und harry
potter und die heiligtümer des todes
okay wir haben fehler dabei augen zu da
waren kein wilder wein du dort alle
fragen nichts fahren
du hast du darfst du jetzt noch mal ja
ich hatte niemals gewusst welcher teil
war für mich ist das cool mal schlau zu
sein
hallo ich habe gesagt dass nicht mehr
was aber wenn du dir alles richtig
beantwortet als belohnung wasser aber
ich will wissen wir nicht erst mal die
nächsten freiwilligen
wir müssen wissen sebastian backer wurde
gestern operiert
das heißt wir können nur auf eine seite
werfen aber er ist ein ehrenamt immer du
bist du gestern heute morgen so dass er
ist ein ehrenmann und er ist trotzdem
starter jan darf ich dir eine von dem
man vertrauen und weil ich habe gerade
schon so viele kaputt gemacht dass ich
nur die eine die ich auch gleich werft
in die hand nehmen kann ich hier nicht
irgend auf dem körper bekommen es ist ja
aber dann war ja nicht bewerben
ich würde sagen wir beginnen mit der
ersten frage eigentlich allgemeinwissen
ist angela merkel jünger oder älter als
60 jahre
das ist sie okay dann schließt die augen
deine antwort ist rolf feltscher 3 1
der markt ist 45 454 50 65 jahre alt
sein
nächste frage wieso die zerstörung der
cdu video zum jetzigen zeitpunkt mehr
als 13 millionen dollar 13 millionen
ja ich habe ich nicht mehr gedeckt da
ist jetzt wirklich übel kann ich nur
sagen endlich
wenn du keine ahnung ich habe keine
ahnung die frage ist auch leute ist der
hype schon vorbei da wird es immer noch
gepflegt das würde immer noch gepflegt
meinte aber ja es hat mehr okay ist hat
die augen zu 33 1
weder ristic züge der einzige der ihr
verpackt hat bisher
du bist auch schon besser als dies tue
das auch schon besser
wir bleiben beim thema wie heißt die
cdu-politikerin mit vollem namen die
regeln für meinungsmache im internet
befördert hat okay annegret kramp
karrenbauer
oder 21
nächste frage lieber sebastian wird ruft
an deinen gefühlen der abonniert es gilt
wiki grad sind es gerade für toleranz
nach oben und unten
das ist tricky also ganz so ernst ist es
wirklich tricky ich habe heute schon in
den wetterbericht reingeschaut
aber was nicht auf der pk ja das ist so
mies alter ich habe zwei zahlen kommen
eine von beiden muss also entweder ich
habe heute gelesen uns auf jeden fall
heute 27 grad wird warm hat man gesehen
dass wir sind
gerade der höhepunkte der
tagestemperatur ist um 19 uhr so 20
erreicht aber es fühlt sich nicht mehr
so intensiv weil die sonne nicht mehr so
drauf bald aber nicht aber die erde ist
schon so war sebastian wie lautet deine
antwort ich sage jetzt einfach mal
möglicherweise droht aber der
sonnenschein trage ich schon okay ich
sage es sind bloss minus 1 grad um 26
grad
ihr seht die antwort 31 aber wie viel
kann das waren 8 und 32 nationen
sonntagabend habe ich hier getroffen
dann wissen weiter in die mitte her dass
unser letzter freiwilliger hat sich bis
jetzt hinter der kamera gestanden das
ist kein geringer als der schönste paar
der welt jakob ich würde sagen ja kob
vergeblich vor die kamera sebastian
films sebastian hat sich eine frage
überlegt für jakob wir haben nämlich
keine mehr dass er muss nur das
improvisieren
wie viele einwohner hat die von uns
allen nicht zu sehr geliebte stadt
düsseldorf plusminus hunderttausend
100.000 50.000 meine mich mal zu
erinnern dass ich mal gehört habe das
ist die hälfte ist von köln
ich sage aber es ist ein bisschen
das schönste paar der wie gesagt es sind
430.000 okay was wir wollten haben wir
bedienen
ok alles klar anschließend 380 bis 400
80.000 heißt würde ich das so nicht
gebaut was ansonsten bisschen fällig 32
[Musik]
über die schulter weg explodiert dann zu
trocken
der bauarbeiter fahrschule lernt etwas
anders war es warm 613.000 der hauptort
du sagst die hälfte von köln jedoch erst
das können die millionen hat ja oder
natürlich ein naja ein bisschen mehr
sagt für und 301 dazu ich hatte auch
überlegt 580.000 30.000 schon heute ich
würde sagen danke dass du dabei warst
jakob durch ich bin ich nicht der
schlechteste gewesen weil ich bin der
zweiten runde rausgeflogen ich den
ersten nachwuchs verlegt die anderen
sind natürlich auch um verlinkt wir
sehen im nächsten video wieder wenn es
wieder heißt nächstes video bei max
[Applaus]